wow
[Applauso]
a grandissima richiesta nuova challenge
la rotta delle penitenze delle torture e
delle sorprese o come già la sono
contento e non vedere ne abbiano cipolla
per raggiungere altre penitenze anche
cosa stragi aspetteresti perché un
esempio dove la scuola ma resta non
potete rimanere la banana potete di
ricordare una banana cosa sarà la buccia
a morsi a casa una scimmia
le sorprese per questo video serre nuovi
orbitz live turisti ronde che sono
appena usciti e li trovate vinicola alle
ore 90 e sono praticamente gli apache
slime
va bene perché appunto non opera in
questo video e voglio vederli sono
troppo curiosa non vedo l'ora che i topi
diretta capitare infatti sono qua nella
ruota qui non vedo l'ora di aprirmi
vedere come sto allora mi raccomando
positivo per me o per evitare o per
tutti e due lasciare un bel live se
volete vedere altri video con la roma e
con le penitenze scrivete ciprini
commenti che ha definite se volete che
facciamo io gli dissi mi hai stiamo a
fare un altro video in cui facciamo le
penitenze e lo sorprende con la ruota il
mio canto a deve capire se una penitenza
la mia solita portata come vedremo
mangiar dare uno sbocco perché la morte
dall'alto vice melo no degli interni
morso locale nonché quando l'economia
magica ma nessuno accanto a in penitenza
[Musica]
ora che è buono ma sulla stretta
transetto protetto tra lo stesso però
set broccoletto vediamo che sapore ha il
blocco e ti piace più come l'olio
[Musica]
ai miei occhi chiusi quindi devo cercare
un time out e prima allora perché che
coprono per non farti vedere sono già
l'immissione bello ancora un giallo e
ora finalmente posso dopo se ti capita e
il bianco glaciale che colora lo slime
borgo che abbiamo subito vedere come
sono che vediamo un po come questo
atlantis live sound dischetto perché
vedete qua sopra c'è lo slime bianco wow
morbidissimo e poi bisogna remo primi
schietto e il dischetto che li separano
e dette così si può visto non mischiare
allora ti preoccupi tanto vediamo come
due super morbido bello togliamo il
dischetto
che bello anche questi sogni giallo
trasparente e super aiutabile
morbidissimo poiché andiamo mischiarlo
abbiamo un po come diventa bello
tantissimo bellissimi poi ora ho
mischiato lo sly in giallo quindi non si
vede bene in trasparenza un vento bianco
si sta rischiando un po bellissimo
scopriamo la bolla che produzioni fmr
fantastico mettiamo il booking
io viaggiavo lettera temi primo modello
dai bene speriamo mostriamo le chiavi di
atm sales di prato ho perso io devo
pensare ancora dai fastidio a verificare
mai detto ma non è stato abbastanza ma
non è nota aveva troppo sole rito allora
sì l'altra è no
[Musica]
tocca a me no ma che sfortuna quindi
stata toccante tutti si stanno capitando
stato quello che tantissimi che si mette
sul ghiaccio asiatici suddito
io poi non era questa salsa piacciono
tantissimo permesso super piccantissima
dei capitali morti
[Musica]
è questo il galaxy steve che non vedevo
l'ora di aprire allora vediamo subito
dove si queste ragazzi stieber
perché trasparente argentato con i
brillantini
ok ecco lo fa apriamo lo abbiamo sempre
lo slime bianco qua sopra
rimuoviamo il di schettino così
rischiamo tavola non lo maneggio questo
questo rimane trasparentissimo
mettiamola in bianco bello della tep
forma che fa una balance cioè una pasta
non avrà sfaticata e di essere argentati
[Musica]
tipo accettato un po bianca desktop e
seppur estendibile ad arte morbido che
vesto distruggerli che fa che ben
aiutato dai dai dai
[Musica]
si no il ragazzo non uccidono credenza
il bianco glaciale che colorano slime
wow
vediamo finito che bello quanti l'inter
infatti non è proprio blu e tipo una
forte di sé per sé ma come chi no non è
vero biancocelesti e verde acqua e
riferimento menti che colore è sì perché
voi celeste verde acqua tigri è infatti
volevo mischiare prima i glitter
[Musica]
wow bellissimo ma che sia sommerso
nell'acqua blandiana bollicine di sorta
con i glitter che sembrano le bollicine
[Musica]
già aperto quindi vi aprirò un altro a
caso che foto un altro peso tutto rosso
che successo si mischiano un po il rosso
sotto canzone sopra no primo diciamo il
fischietto quindi il dischetto
ora che con l'arricchimento e secondo te
è una volta che lo richiamo secondo me
viene fuori arancione secondo me rosso
vediamo che in cucina nostro bellissimo
e tipo un po chiesa
mettiamolo a diventando rozzo e ragione
però è un po rosso rosso peperone
ingaggiato letterato tre sono meno
[Musica]
liberi anche tu puoi pescare senza
guardare non mi sembra rosa rosa posto
la scelta di un viola plan puglia una
maglia come l'anguria serie molto bello
perché è bello proprio no balance
davvero bello mi tocca a me
già che porterete del fenomeno remix per
amore vi capita per il galaxy gold che è
quello dorato fitter dorato in più
serate già un po mischiato con il bianco
vediamo un po come riteniamo il
dischetto
nell'inter donati ma questo super
morbide e super lucido bellissimo
andiamo a schiacciarla per colore
bellissimo e miracoli 3d 3 momento anche
di terza età
[Musica]
vede dai sentito di rimuovere così cifre
ea chiedersi come la banana oddio di
notte primarie che sia molto evidente
destro con la buccia buono tremando
buono prende tutte le penitente in modo
buono un altro pochissimo il rumore
[Risate]
non meno che vede mi sarebbe capitato
qualche foto verde vediamo un po
certamente non voglio rischiarlo ma
voglio fare l'effetto a valence come lei
fa tutto con il coppia detto che figo e
morbidissimo guardatelo si sta
mischiando e ora lo lascia un po così
vediamo come diventa attore di sliven
proprio alta
ultimo turno capitale e ultimo turno per
mcqueen speriamo che mica migliora 3
flier non è che per campionato
[Musica]
picchettare borsetto maggio era stato il
momento di dire marroncino ma se allora
aspetta è fermo
[Musica]
che carino cifre che rimane sempre così
dipendente promette dalla 10 quando di
sapere la stessa chitarre ti trovi bella
mi trovo bellissima zio curate bus live
al limite si è spaventato di meco un
senso dato che mi metto giù dalla torre
ultimo giorno per me e poi abbiamo
finito schermi capiterà tripla più
sfortunato di così oggi i mittenti
quindi è qualcosa di rotta questo modo
questo viola però questo è bello perché
viola un bellissimo che viola e mia rosa
chiaro tipo pastello molto bellissimo ci
vedete la promessa che belli fuori
completati certo super hi tech e suoni
eventi assolutamente volete vedere un
altro video di ruota della impenitente
delle sorprese di senza grosseto prova
dei trucchi scrivete i vostri consigli
nei commenti invito di divertita un
sacco con il tempio di un po meno
su pubblicare per vedere i prossimi
video i nostri video divertenti i nostri
challenge il video cliccate su quella
che preferite e non facciamo rossetto